please welcome the one we hope the only
triple h
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that was some good acting on your part
you got a hell of a grip
yes i do i'm quite a man
now let's talk here you are probably the
best
bad guy in the world you're very good at
it you enjoy it don't you you enjoy
being the bad guy
yeah it's what i uh it's what i live for
when the people are
booing or they're screaming and spitting
at me and that's what i live for i mean
it's the
it sounds weird but it's the best part
of my job and the funny thing about our
industry is that
most times the baddest bad guys tend to
be the nicest guys
personally yeah you know and the good
guys tend to be the biggest jerks you
know
i mean pretty much like you i mean
that's the best you've got that's it
i'm serious i met him backstage he comes
off as a great guy out here right he's
all smiling happy making you laugh
backstage what a jerk you're the biggest
biggest hollywood piece of crap i ever
met that's all you've got that you can't
do better than that don't understand
they don't
they don't understand they don't
understand that the booing makes you
stronger
it makes me strong like bull
but i am a big jerk backstage it's what
i enjoy doing uh do people
uh by the way you're a fat head
is this your attempt at doing what i do
for a living inciting people i think if
i started being like a real
bad guy i think it would be i mean our
show our ratings couldn't probably get
any higher than they are now
but i think if i started my change my
whole persona and went after people just
like you
i think that the show would just really
take off and if you had an attitude
a bad attitude jerk
look at my long hair i mean come on you
look like uh fabio on crack i mean
[Applause]
[Laughter]
no
just kidding oh great i wet myself
such you forgot the you forgot the first
rule of being a bad guy
is you can talk trash but you have to be
able to get back together yeah i don't
have the backing up thing if i took my
jacket off my torso would fall under the
ground
it's the only thing holding me together
right like a coat hanger with meat
hanging off
now you're sort of like shaky green yeah
you're don rickles yeah
now people actually carry signs at these
wrestling matches they carry signs that
say how much they hate you is there
and you have to look you you have to
look at that
comeback yeah you have to you have to
look at these signs which i think would
be really
difficult to see what's what sign has
particularly stuck out lately
i uh i mean we get all kinds of signs i
mean from
you know people hating us a lot of them
are the same sometimes there's original
ones
i'm actually my favorite sign because
i'm a big fan of the show believe it or
not
my favorite sign was just a little bit
ago there was a sign in the crowd and uh
one of the sayings that i say all the
time is that i'm that damn good
right right and uh it was a sign that
said triple h
is that damn good and when the guy
flipped the sign over it said for me to
poupon
and i really thought that was great i'm
a big triumph fan you know
i like the image of you being happy for
a second and then uh
did uh do you uh do you ever smile
because in all the footage i've seen of
you you're never
smiling have you ever smiled once in the
ring that you can remember
one time yeah about a year ago maybe a
little bit less than that we there's a
wrestler that wrestles for us named al
snow
and i was wrestling al snow in a match
on on television
and uh i picked them up for a suplex and
what's the suplex
basically a move where i hold the guy
straight up in the air his head's here
his legs are straight up and here i let
the blood rusher's head for about 10-15
seconds and then drop him backwards
yeah i do that sometimes if i a little
sticky situation yeah
so um i grabbed him by his trunks and as
i went to pick him up i held him up for
about five or six seconds and i heard
the crowd start to laugh
and i was kind of confused for a second
the referee came around the front side
looked up and went oh god and started to
laugh
and i looked up and realized that his
trunks had slid
all the way over to this side and he had
nothing on underneath his truck
right and the hard part is people are
laughing
which yeah which i can attest this is
not a pleasant situation it should have
been it
it looked like a grub worm was trying to
burrow out of a football all right
wow yeah you're like james joyce with
these images
it was beautiful wonderful images here
so anyways i ended you know just
the crowd was laughing i was laughing i
gave him the suplex and on the way down
i just said
oh you know
and uh
it was you could have used another word
you could have said your grub worm is
showing
but no that's not your style you sell
uh you you're actually a lot of a lot of
stuff a lot of
a lot of triple h souvenirs are selling
for a lot of money
on ebay is this true um we actually wwf
has our own auction site
right and uh we do you know part of the
proceeds to that go to charity and
they'll sell
you know fans our fans are crazy they're
kind of like trekkies but not nerds you
know
and and they'll buy no no they're
they're they're they're trekkies that
can do some serious damage
yeah if you if you uh if you get in
their face yeah but
they'll buy just about anything you know
i mean uh
i've signed chairs that i've got whacked
in the head with that just had my blood
smattered all over them and
signed it and they'll auction them off
and they don't they don't clean the
blood off they keep the blood on no
that's the uh
that's the thrill of that blood actually
makes it worth more
have you ever like if you're hard up
would you just never like get like 10
chairs ahead of you and just think
yeah you know i jab myself in the head
and
you gotta get a couple of bucks yeah you
always have that to fall back on you
know what's really weird is that i'm
just
you can't help but notice your arm is
like my leg you know
it's and no actually it's not
this is my leg right here that part is
my leg that's the only thing i recognize
on you is my anatomy
what is that's a mate can you get
implants that do that i would just oh
look at that there's like a
it's like there's a little it's like
there's a person in there
it's like you have it you hire a dwarf
to hang push up
no
easy
i am some whoop ass you do not want to
open that's
that's what you don't want to mess with
me seriously seriously you don't
i because people don't know this people
on tv i play this guy who was a nerd
got my little tie and stuff but when i
don't even take my clothes off when the
show's over i flex when they fly off you
just spread them
i walk out when it shows over and i go
oh like that
[Music]
and i'm completely naked and i walk the
halls that is a talent to have
well well i've never been so full of
crap as i am tonight on the show
now and one thing i want to ask you is
you're very very good
at at just sort of generating that anger
and that hatred and that that that mean
look
out there do you ever after a really
really tough match is over
do you ever go back you know back into
the dressing room and actually hang out
with the guy that you've been beating
on for the last 20 minutes half hour
yeah i mean sometimes you know
i mean what we do you know guys get
along some guys don't get along and and
you know there's a it's kind of the
honor among thieves things we'll kind of
hang around
afterwards and tell each other how great
we were you know and uh
it's it's the shame it's the same in the
talk show world i'm sure you do in the
back yeah
yeah i go back there leno's back there
tonight yeah i was good
yeah i was good your team looked great
but uh there was actually uh just a
little while ago
a funny story is uh i was at madison
square garden we had a pay-per-view
there
um called the royal rumble and i fought
mick foley right uh actually
cactus jack you've been on here before
yes he's been here and uh it was a
particularly
uh violent match it was a street fight
my
you guys are like hitting each other
with chains chairs we went at it with
everything we had
two by fours covered in barbed wire uh
there were twenty thousand thumbtacks in
the ring
yeah i mean we did what a wonderful
sport
yeah i got a hole punctured in my leg
and and uh
as soon as after the match is over i've
got stitches in my legs stitches in my
head i've got
i look like a spirit of 76 like the drum
player the
big bandage around my head mick foley's
back there same thing he's all bandaged
up and vince mcmahon is back there we're
all standing around laughing and talking
and i look over and there's my mother
bawling her eyes out in the doorway
because she just
watched her baby son get torn apart on
right in front of her eyes about three
rolls back you know wait no that's
that saps him of his strength sympathy
will take away his power only booing
she was a true heel i just yelled at her
and then
yeah kicked her and we were out of there
hey i like i like how you thought people
were gonna boo you
kicking your mom but our crowd's like ah
all right yeah
that is a new york crowd well uh the uh
summerslam is on august 27th on
pay-per-view
and uh triple h very nice to have you
here thank you very much